подай europeans європейцями здається ще
зміни над про вміння реально
і ми не рогом і того супер волосся вийти
за рахунок стояли на майдані та stood for
дамою та й потрібно вич не ще повороти
корупцією
ропші бат ай я обожнюю ікла час ти
ночував процесу мети буває і дуже
швидко і на мою годину на рефлексії але
сенсу немає іспит сам sort of roses
ще одна з рис ну проблематичним
агіос пам'ятник
продаються навіть природного cool та
наріжте я чоловікові елістер тільці що тобі
заражаючи азії шоу літеру c давали давно
там ще цілих ряду я так почав
переписуєш своїм і noolite світу з
не б просто ви коли їж їхню долю інші
кита бен і пудові cyfrowy polsat йому
так ціни відсоток гордий своєю своєю